okay I'm back it's a lot of light around
me it's been a while since i've streamed
from like my home so I've been traveling
a lot I was in Europe for a month and a
half and I was in st. Louis I was at a
hotel over the weekend for a tournament
but now I'm back this is not gonna be a
long stream I would be very surprised if
this goes beyond one hour but okay who
knows I already have a challenge from
all drown
I guess we'll play him first challenger
I played this person before twice before
I have won twice okay Oh what do I want
to do let's play a new opening let's
let's play this candy in honor of JB and
I'll play I'll actually play that um
what do we call this the knight f6
variation I think it has a more enticing
name but it's a solid variation for a
black especially if I win the pawn back
right away and there's some idea for a
white like if Y wants to play in the
main line it involves Bishop c4 in Queen
f3 but we'll see if he knows that okay
he knows Bishop c4 and hello to people
in the chat
I mean rearrange my windows here so I
can see everything
hello Jack C hello Gabriel Thomas Newton
hello the nice guy cool guy a few
different guys here
no no uh if I prefer nice over cool mmm
probably both there needs to be someone
that called it a nice cool guy
kay Kratz good to see you okay so he
didn't play coming up three which is
slightly disappointing because I've I've
had a really cool idea with against
Queen f3 in this line I I assumed Bishop
g4 should be played and then II six and
then it's just a very solid position
get the kind of typical Scandinavian
structure with Bishop d6 and 97 in Queen
c7 just what I want
yeah cake rats ah good to see you too
the tournament went okay if I hadn't won
my last round I would have won like $500
but I drew so I won $30 it was slightly
disappointing because I was winning my
last round game but then in the final
position I got my whole advantage slip
and final position my opponent was like
plus six and agreed to a draw because we
were both in severe time pressure and it
was just a ridiculous situation where it
was very unclear what was going on so
sometimes that happens when money is on
the line you got banned by Ben Feingold
because you said I was a better player
than him I think my record my record
against Ben Feingold is like probably
zero wins and a bunch of bosses at least
an online chess but maybe I'm just
better than him in real life I don't
know with B 3 he's letting me just
completely destroy his pawn structure I
can give him two sets of double pawns
but I don't know how bad that would be
for him I also have this move Queen f6
or Bishop d6 and b3 is giving me a lot
of options I'm not sure what to do I'm
very much inclined just to play like an
endgame let's play an endgame we're
gonna trade everything and buy
everything I just mean the Knights and
the queens and now the bishop for the
Knights and then I'll get some position
where it'll turn into decisional chess
and I'll start with 97 the most flexible
move
he's thinking probably because he's
scared I'm playing so quickly did the
stream get messed up I hope not I seem
to be live
maybe it's your connection maybe it's
mine let me know if people can hear and
see me okay I'm using I'm still using my
like my cheap portable mic I have my
blue Yeti still on my shelf I need to
return it I need to like make a ticket
with with the company and then they'll
give me like an order form and I can
ship it to them then it will take like
two weeks for them to ship me a new one
well I ever come to Argentina I'll look
up are there any like international
events in Argentina because usually if I
want to go to some place I'll find a
tournament that offers like nice
conditions and then I have a nice excuse
to go to that place so I can play ninety
five here at Bishop e2 and develop my
other Bishop
they'll start with 95 why not improve a
piece make one of his pieces worse I'm
not sure what the follow-up will be
though because now my night is just
restricted and perhaps a target in the
center I think maybe I'll play like
Bishop e7 and just maybe eventually
Knight g6 there's another move that's
sticking out here which I think I'm
gonna play first it looks strange but
I'm gonna play Age 5
the idea is if he plays f4 I want to put
my knight here and then develop my
Bishop here and then attack his pawn but
he doesn't go into any of that so let's
play my g6 attack the bishop
good-afternoon Kovu Kovu is from
Australia writes because it's tomorrow
there and this afternoon there you gotta
remember that correctly Bishop e7 it's a
normal move it's played Bishop e7
this is gonna be somewhat of a fight
it was very positional now he plays that
for now the problem for me I can't
Castle queenside because that's illegal
and if I Castle kingside it allows rook
d7 so there's a few moves that come to
mind one is Bishop f6 attack the pawn
and the other is Knight h4 to come to f5
and I might play these moves in
combination let's start with this this
initiative he can't really play Bishop
d4 because I went a four so rook to e3
okay maybe now it's a coup it's a cheer
no joke wait okay I have to focus
I'll answer questions later no joke
aren't you streaming
go back to your stream I just saw you
streaming like a couple minutes ago but
you're welcome to stay here if you'd
like
Brooke d8 rip d AIDS
taketake here here looks okay I think it
helps to trade one pair of rooks just so
he can't penetrate too much on the D
file
wait did no joke under the stream oh it
was a raid from no joke I didn't even
see that because it doesn't make a sound
when there's a raid thanks no joke
I mean I would give you a percentage of
bits but I like I tried cheering on your
channel and then it didn't let me cheer
so I'm I feel like I'm very much
restricted I couldn't take the pawn that
was a good trade a 7 pawn for a pawn or
was it ok cuz my king is if he can see 8
or probably King see 7 I'm so indecisive
probably King c7 because now I have two
threats and now just this right it's a
free pawn so he no longer has double
pawns
because I won two of them and now I
would just like to play 95 and be happy
I would also like to play rook t8 but
that would run into Bishop b6
so I have to be a little bit careful
let's play 95 Hey however I still don't
know how to pronounce your name halt
vard hf thanks for the host it's going
well do I take
no it's retreats
I like my Center okay
now that I'm up a pond I can answer
questions I still have to move so now
we'll have an officer Clara Bishop
position I'll still be up a pond
probably play f6 always play off six and
I don't know what to do
h4 I want my pawns on light squares to
restrict his bishop
so probably g6 defending the H pawn and
then I'll put my rook on the D file how
to play against the London it's a good
question I could try and demonstrate
that if anyone plays the London against
me
warm water with sugar again technically
yes except the warm water is now tea and
the sugar is honey so I've upgraded
since my my previous beverage Arab tea
for looks pleasant I just want to win
all these pawns
I also maybe you want to play rook h4
target this pond but then he plays h3
come to Utah are you in Utah I have a
student from Utah which I might I might
end up going to Utah at some point I've
been there once in childhood it's a nice
state do they do here more bits wait I
have to stay focused
sir doodle pants that's a new name I
think I've seen that name before
thank you sir doodle pants and hello
chess BAE
how's it going
just pay I just got your message yeah I
completely agree with your message f-for
I kind of forgot about but I can take I
can take and then return to e5 defending
my pawn and obstructing his rook and
attacking the bishop some nice geometry
here
I was talking to someone on Leach s
other day and they sent me like five
messages in a row but in and then he
apologized for sending so many messages
and he said sorry for all the but
instead of messages he wrote massages so
he apologized for all of the massages
speaking of massaging I'm about to
massage his rook on e6 so this is like a
amazing move I defend everything I
threaten the bishop and now I'm chopping
my rook
life is so good my tea is so good this
is a new tea oolong tea just calming
relaxing no caffeine I would like to
take the bishop and just win the King
pawn ending but that's completely not
necessary let's just win upon sounds
tasty but might be a waste of coffee
grounds is that referring to my tea
let's pin him again I want to provoke
Qing Yi for so then his Bishop is more
stuck did that do anything maybe now
King to do maybe this aha
I will respond to your message to the
person who just messaged me but I will
respond after this stream the answer is
yes though but not okay I'll explain
later let me take this oh I have to be
careful because rook take a 6 would lose
or it would draw that was close now he
should have probably taken right away
but okay this is just an easy win
wait is there law is there caffeine and
who long tea okay let's take this whoa
it's Nathan Nathan with a tier three sub
where did that come from
thanks Nathan Nathan I haven't seen you
in like a few weeks it's been a while
but you're in school right so that's a
decent excuse what do I do here so I've
used my King and then push pawns why
would that be a draw because there was
there is a dirty tactic at some point if
I do this
he takes I do this he takes yeah he's
way outside the box I might want to
demonstrate that endgame though because
there there was a potential cool idea
where if I had blundered that it would
have been kind of neat wait a minute do
this have to be precise now my opponent
is stalling delaying defeat okay good
game all Brown what happened in that
game oh yeah the Scandinavian so there's
a few things I can talk about there's
actually one thing I want to mention
it's I have a really cool story about
this position after Queen f3 but I think
I'll save that for another time because
I need to get permission from someone
but okay let's go forward here so this
position again
I turned down my volume I'm gonna mute
the tab here just so it's not too loud
and then yeah I just wanted to show this
one moment cool story about the trophies
there's a lot more trophies than what
you see in the background there's
trophies on like both sides I could give
a story about trophies at some point I
was really happy with this move Bishop
e5 I'm going to show this to students
and take a screenshot such a great
multipurpose move it pins if defends it
threatens to trap and then I almost
blundered I think I nearly pre moved row
take a 6 - luckily this didn't happen
because c5 check would occur and then
we'd reach this position which should
just be a draw because White has a
bishop but not enough pawns only one
pawn and though I'm not sure king d6
yeah this is a draw there's some weird
situation like let's imagine we get some
position where I just run to the corner
and he takes oh is this still a draw I
thought this was winning four lights why
this table they say it's a draw because
I like it's a wrong color corner for the
bishop so if this Jeep on didn't exist
it's it's just a dead draw but I thought
with the Jeep on existing white is
winning somehow with achieving some
stalemate idea King h7 here I can move
back and forth
yeah I guess why can never force me to
h8 the the winning idea for white is if
the King moves to h8 then white can
stalemate the king and force g5 and then
it's winning so I thought there are some
situations where white could actually
force this but maybe not in this
position anyway it's a good thing to
know cool story about the trophies I
just grabbed the closest trophy I could
find which is this one people can see it
kind of well it's cool shot with the
reflection of the board this trophy was
one part of the pan-american
intercollegiate teams championship and
it was third place it was back when I
played for University of Illinois we
were the only team that qualified for
Final Four two years in a row
that didn't have any like scholarships
for chess players didn't have a coach we
were completely student-run and we were
competing against the top dogs Webster
in the Texas schools good memories got a
lot of media attention
we took fourth place in the Final Four
but just getting to the Final Four was
incredible and we were featured on a
bunch of like news outlets and we we
ended up raising we had to raise money
because our school like didn't fund our
trip to the Final Four so we end up like
starting a campaign some kind of
donation campaign raised over $10,000
for the teams so that was that was
pretty cool but yeah most of my other
trophies I'm actually planning to get
rid of just because they take up space
and they're from a lot of old scholastic
tournaments which actually brings up the
question how do I get rid of old
trophies because I I don't know and if
anyone knows let me
No if it helps I'm in the Chicago area
so I could auction them off maybe what
people actually like what them or like
buy them from me I mean I'd be happy to
like donate them to something but anyway
let's accept some other challenge I
could melt them and then bury them and I
want to play so indecisive give me a
random number between one and four three
be traumatic oh I think I played Germont
ego before I could put them in the
garbage but that's kind of sad
good luck dramatical
I could do a photoshoot with them that
would be actually kind of cool Oh what
do I do here play Knight of six people
can recommend openings I can't play this
candy now that he played d4 he might
actually play a London and someone was
asking earlier what to play against the
London so this could be a prime
opportunity never mind I'll play a huge
ad I'll probably go for a semi Slav
depending what he does yeah and if he
allows me I would love to play Cambridge
Springs a3 a3 prevents the Cambridge
Springs but I don't think a3 is a great
move but why is it a bad move maybe this
move because in many cases I like if he
plays slowly I can just get away with
winning upon DJ chess dog I can say the
same thing about having a picture with
you a majority of people on this planet
don't have the picture with you so that
makes me feel special
oh let's play Knight e5 and Gabriel
Thomas Newton has been watching all my
streams and knows my frustration I've
been trying to play the Cambridge
Springs but no one goes into it
but that's maybe a good thing because
they go into more dubious lines so DJ
chess dog okay I see chess Bay's
conference so there is a there is a
savant in st. Louis during okay during
the whole month of August between the
Sinquefield Cup and the grand chest tour
and over the course of the event there
were a lot of people I like came up and
like asked for photos with me and asked
for autographs and it was really cool
and there is one person in particular
that like recognized me from streaming
and okay we chatted briefly and I don't
know if we took a photo together
but maybe it was possible anyway I found
out just a few days ago that the person
was one of my like idols when I back
when I was in high school in college the
one and only Patrick JMT who has like
almost a million subscribers on YouTube
I had no idea was him because he doesn't
show his face in his videos well it was
so weird that he recognized me and I
didn't recognize him so I'll have to see
if I have a photo with him actually but
anyway I'm up upon yes double pawns I
have double pawns
this is yeah I'm terribly frustrated
right now that I can't play the
Cambridge Springs you mentioned the
other day a lot of what people do I
suggest in terms of chess youtubers John
Bartholomew by far who else
Nicolas who shoulda been who maybe not
too many people have heard of he was
very active a while ago now I think
recently he's been more active I've been
watching agate mater's videos too
recently because I think he has like a
good approach that he keeps it simple
chest network of course is a classic I
know everyone has different preferences
so I don't
I don't know what I'm trying to say
yeah I mean everyone has their own style
so it's about kind of finding people
that you you learn well from or you
you're entertained by and then I'm just
pursuing those people I mean Ben
Feingold's another one who and people
just love also thanks to the sub the new
sub who what's his name
Oh who was gifted by Amon somani
to dev dogs dev dog XXX that's a new
name appreciate the love so it has a
little bit of compensation like he has
more space and now some attack against
his pawn he's threatening to different
funds he's threatening to take here and
to take care so maybe Queen c7 and solve
everything
he's been Feingold emotes roar in the
time of Nick good to see you back I did
watch Carlsen stream but I only watched
it live I think once because the other
time he streamed she one time he
streamed to you as having connection
problems then another time he streamed
was for a Tyrell arena which I was doing
like the official commentary for leech s
so Magnus had all the like all the
viewers and then I was just talking to
myself but I of course I rewatched the
streams and it was fascinating just
watching him play bullets and listening
to like gangster music and everything
ok let's complete developments and
Fabiano has stream to like both of them
have streams like within the last
several months I doubt that they're
gonna stream anytime soon especially
before the match but maybe it's possible
okay so I'm finally kind of completing
developments also there is time factor
she has a minute left and there's no
increment and now I have two bishops
let's play g6 I want to play h5 h4 and
maybe you just keep my rook on h8 I'll
put my King on f8 if the centre opens up
yeah the thing about top chess player is
streaming is at least okay with Hikaru
like he has a lot of events happening
between okay between those events in
August and now the this showdown event
next week and then the limpy it after
that so I don't know if we'll see her
karo back would like to see him back but
I'm sure he's just taking a break from
chess but I have not seen his cool new
emotes I have to check those out I'm
happy with my pawn structure almost
everything is on light squares feels
like dross which I haven't played drops
in a while it's been so long
yeah the showdown is is coming up it
starts on the 11th I think is the first
day that they play is it time to castle
it's time to castle dramatical is
actually playing a good game for his
raining it's provisional but he hasn't
blundered too severely yet
that looks like a free pound have I
tried the Magnus app the only time I
play on the Magnus app is when I'm on a
plane and there's no Wi-Fi it's the only
thing I have to do and then I'll play
like I'll try and work my way up but I
forget what age I started having trouble
against oh yeah there's a protest League
thing Saturday - what's exciting I have
to put that in my calendar remind me
about protesting on Saturday I said
protest League and it says protesting
but hopefully I'll remember what that
means okay so oh dramatical is in the
chat thanks for the game also dead man
DM thanks for the 50 more bits leading
the bit war and what was that I'm in
some money with a hundred and with a
hundred bits he wants me to play him is
he challenging me oh he is okay I'll
play Amundsen money good luck bribe
accepted there's a board off give some
more margin here okay hopefully that's
better good luck I'm in some money no no
wait I want to play
running out of cool lines against d4 I'm
gonna play what I played I went through
a phase in my life it only lasted like a
few months but I went through a phase
where I played c5 d5 f5 and during this
phase I gained like a hundred points I
went from 2,300 feet a to 2,400 feet a
and I got to I am norms so somehow it
worked out but he doesn't want any of
that oh he wants to play a London maybe
let's uh let's maybe trying to allow it
I'll play this
yeah Bishop at 4 it's gonna be a London
okay so for whoever was asking about
what to play and some London earlier
this is a setup I recommend if you can
get to this position with white doing
the usual triangle stuff you can take
advantage of it with Queen b6 this is
the main target in White's position and
now for white to the Fenby - he has to
make some kind of concession queen c1 is
a very playable move usually people play
queen bee threes I actually have to
think now I think I will take on d4
first and then just go for a bishop I
five have a slightly more active
position and the idea is actually
together rook to c8 relatively soon -
perhaps target the Queen like already
he's playing slowly like h3 is kind of a
slow move which could potentially be
punished with a move like night before
because then there it's there's a pin on
the C file and I don't think he can
defend C - I'm very curious to see what
he's going to do after this
Roy Davis is the most feared chess
player to walk the earth as Roy Davis
challenging me I don't see oh I do see a
right Davis interesting so this is uh
yeah this is what you get for playing
slightly too slowly in the opening can I
request a piece sack for voyboy or you
know what does that even mean when
possible is y or you know boyo I can't
even pronounce that boy arre no is that
a person boy no
I'm so confused oh so this is another
person in the chat and I have to sack
something it's hard to sack when I'm
just winning material for free maybe
I'll win something and then sacrifice oh
you tried to get my attention I wasn't
paying attention I saw the thing I just
got the attention a Tom and some money
I'm so confused
it's too much to keep track of I will
sack when the time is right
but this position does not call for
sacking do I play Knight seat Orser yeah
let's play Knight c2 and I'll win the
exchange really I was just wanting to
satisfy the person earlier who had who
was asking how to play against the
London hopefully this is a nice
demonstration ok now I'll look for sax
g5 I just want to I won't just want to
get a position first
I see the comment from a mule v DW at
least too much because I interact too
much yeah it's a hard balance to like
interact with the chat and play decent
chess but I try my best if there's
nothing on the line then I will usually
interact more the last stream I did I
was blundering all over the place it was
really bad but that's life so now I'm
going for the King side attack he was
kind of overextended I was giving a
lesson earlier today about whenever the
opponent has pawns like this it's a very
thematic break to play pawn h5
especially with a rook on h8 the
interaction is appreciated okay that's
good to hear 95 is kind of annoying
let's play f6 always play f6 and then
after he takes I'll take back with the
pawn what's my favorite programming
language I don't know I want to say HTML
but that's I don't count that as a
language I started with with JavaScript
and Java and then C++ probably Java
that's probably what I've done the most
with I'm actually curious if I have I
might have some applications I made
saved on my computer but do I want to
search for them now let me search for it
Eclipse no I was programming an eclipse
back like five years ago I made the
chess program I made a boggle game but
recently I haven't done too much
programming I do more more front-end
stuff now okay so what does this my
knight wanted to maybe g5 and maybe the
sack is coming up the sack will be on h3
unless he does that I still sack let's
do this
I don't know why I traded Queens but I
just having pawns like this like double
pawns next to each other there's
something really satisfying about that
okay now I'll sack I'm gonna sack the
night because I want triple plants I'm
gonna play rook c7 and then we'll take
the rook on each one and then it'll be
some interesting endgame this will
actually be a very instructive and game
because then it's a matter of how to win
with the rook against some minor pieces
and this like this is just a bad
position for lack now I went from just
what should have been easily winning is
now I'm gonna have to actually work for
it and the hope with this was actually
to some day got quadruple pawns I'm not
sure if that's going to happen I'm gonna
start with b3 just to restrict his
Knight and then very soon I would like
to play this in this also something
popped up but I missed it
oh I took five mins on my name is
hosting me long time no see
thanks for the host any advice for a
1400 whose main tactic is hoping they
don't see all the blunders there's many
more things to chess than hoping your
opponent doesn't see all the blunders
and it's one thing to don't even want to
say to that I mean a lot about chess is
minimizing blunders and capitalizing on
Mondays that your opponent makes but
there's more like improving your pieces
to get to a point where you'll have
tactics and learning like the underlying
positional strategy there's many layers
to chess beyond just the nature of
wandering
ninja is back hello ninja I'm your chess
hero that's so flattering okay I want to
do this I want to invade with my rook
the nice thing about this position is
none of my pawns are weak even my
isolated pawn my triple pawns
they're very hard for him to attack and
easy for me to defend I think that's a
really important definition like if you
have to define a weakness and chess it's
something that's hard to attack right
now a weakness in chess is something
that's easy to attack and hard to defend
so this applies in many different cases
with pawns and squares and King safety
what's my favorite Canadian city I've
never been to Canada I've never been to
Mexico just kind of sad I've been to
Australia Indonesia I've been to like 15
to 20 different countries over the last
year but never Canada I don't know I've
heard good things about Montreal though
okay my rook is going to invade it's
hard to break through though there's
like no pawn breaks on the Kings side I
have a form I have a four on two
majority that's really sad maybe I don't
even know let's check him again
how do I play against the Scotch
[Music]
that's a good question I like to play
the bishop before check line which it
took me a like years to understand why
you play Bishop before check and then go
back to c5 but that's what I like to do
because it's lesser-known and it's very
flavorful
now when you say Scotch I assume a 45 93
96 d4 pawn to d4 Knight take d4 and
that's where I play Bishop before check
I'm stuck I'm gonna move back here
defend my Jeep on and then what and I
came to a happier place this could be
along ooh he's leaving upon undefended
this is going to be a long grind
okay well repeat once
and I want to play okay so we've we've
repeated twice actually but I want to do
this
I don't know what my plan is that's the
problem actually helped me like if I
didn't have a pawn on g5 my King could
infiltrate play this connect six
vertically vertically like this that's
sounds really difficult
okay I have an idea finally but involves
playing King d6 first it actually
involves triangulating cuz he's moving
his light back and forth this is gonna
be funny he's gonna play Knight b3 no he
doesn't
okay I'll still triangulate
so I want to waste a tempo okay so I've
triangulated and now he'll go back to b3
and now I play a five this is my winning
attempt it's risky though because it
couldn't involve losing but oh he does
that it's no fun he's playing safe well
let's walk my king back here I see what
he's doing he's basically arguing that
he has a fortress and challenging me to
break through that's also annoying let's
play for preventing him from playing a4
also preventing him from playing Knight
b3 and now the goal is to squeeze him
somehow if he was an orange maybe I
could make orange juice I'm gonna start
with a check and then maybe do this it's
heon's looks long I think he's in his
legs long he has no good moves
easy win I'm now just assuming he's
watching and my only feasible way of
winning is to mess with him but it means
looks long as the only real option to
win this I think this is a read that
game - it's not a wise decision
very poor decision on my parts but I'm
trying I'm trying all my ideas maybe
I'll try sacking kanji for
I'm also sacking on g6 we'll see if he
wants to take the pawn no he takes it
it's unexpected but kind of expected
I'll move back here and then let's put
the rook here
I don't think losing the g6 pawn helps
or hurts either of us it was just a
nothing pawn the good thing is about
losing the g6 pawned is okay that was
moved fifty five so the 50 move rule
could come into play at some point and
that will be very relevant so this is
gonna be a very long grind Bishop g6
interesting now I no longer have triple
pawns which is a bit unfortunate
and he was moving back and forth it's
unfortunate
trying all of my ideas this is really
difficult
I have one more idea though it involves
some magic yeah I have a really cool he
has an idea - I did not CC for coming so
he's playing for the win maybe or is he
c4 is really interesting okay now I have
to think I have to defend stuff now
so he had an easy draw in his hand but
he's going for more which involves
taking some risk so move the rook back
have to defend this pond
and now I have to bring my king in he's
threatening Bishop d5 okay let's bring
my king in further ooh wait this could
be really bad I'm gonna bring my came to
c7
I probably shouldn't have sacrificed ng5
but I'm trying my best
looking c7 I think is a great square for
the king what's the splits rating okay
so hopefully he'll be slow
interesting move well he's playing like
in a very controlled sense he's taking
very little risks which makes it
difficult for me to accomplish anything
but I'm gonna keep grinding and by
grinding I just mean surviving and he's
gonna win the pawn wait now there's some
calculation and I'm gonna calculate in
silence just for good measure yeah let's
play this first
the good thing about my king is it's far
away from his knight in terms of
checking distance so it takes like three
moves for his Knight to check me
so my king is is very well placed
defending the b-pawn and now this D pawn
is somewhat of the target and if he
moves it then he leaves his knight
undefended so at some point I might be
happy with a draw I play this move rook
f6 oh he is happy that your how cuz he
offered me a draw that's funny but I
don't want to draw I want to win but how
do I win
I have one idea involves taking a
massive risk let's go for it
because now if he takes the pawn I
target d4 and that'll be actually really
interesting there is a two second
increment so it's may be hard to flag
him but okay we'll see
97 attacking the rook I have to be
careful rook here or to the h-file now
this is getting really interesting
hmm
let's move here far away and then I'll
come invade from behind attacking from
the rear Wow
interesting move let's play this
it's all about the active rook and now I
have a very clear idea which I think I
can get away with immediately with rook
p1 and then I'm just gonna attack his
pawns like a3 is now the major target
not sure how he's gonna stop rook b3
this is finally a moment where I I feel
like he's he's been tricked and he's a
long time
Bishop there I don't think does anything
let's win upon it feels so good to win
something I haven't won anything for so
long I'm still nervous though because
it's still incredibly complex I still
have no idea what's going on but his
time is telling a good story
do I take on a three or do I make him
think somehow no let's take out a 3 and
rookie a 1 now I have a passed pawn and
life is good it's still not over like
this still takes a ton of work to win
this position
it's very complex still think I want to
go for this I don't want to give him too
much more time to think ooh okay I was
expecting something else what to do I
have the outside passer go for this this
has gotta be way more stressful for him
given that he has four seconds left and
I can take my sweet time maybe now I go
for a rugby one cut off his king
threatening this he goes back now I can
check him making progress but now I'm
stuck how do I get stuck like that does
rookie 3 work rookie 3 take take it
probably doesn't work let's play this
now I'm below a minute okay I have to
speed it up
rook b1 rook here maybe
you just playing this game of moving
back and forth which is kind of annoying
let's play rook d1 I'm just trying to
confuse him whoo free pawn house nice so
I successfully confused him I got rid of
his most dangerous pawn approaching one
move 100 how do I win this check him and
then attack the pawn ok one I guess
waiting move
this is frustrating okay pretty soon I
have to speed things up
like a lot
hmm I'm feeling the pressure
oh my gosh I want to take on e4 it
doesn't work though I lost my most
valuable pawn that's really sad I have
one idea too he resigned why did he
resign
I'm so confused at first I thought it
was a threefold claim that was such a
weird ending I'm I'm confused why he
resigned too though I was gonna try rook
b8 and then somehow walk my king I don't
know if I could have penetrated that was
really anti comply Matic maybe he
offered a draw but is a draw button next
to the resign button good game I mean he
put up a really good fight
[Music]
how many moves was that there's a lot of
moves I was really trying to win somehow
in that position but it wasn't easy and
yeah you have to confirm resign I wasn't
really paying attention to the chat am i
a GM yet no I am NOT a GM yet okay let's
go and play someone else someone wanted
me to play someone but I forgot who that
someone was
I'm looking for names that sound vaguely
familiar
Roy Davis sounds familiar
I don't know like he's he was someone
who was mentioned I think not sure who
it was though hopefully people were
entertained with that let's play
hey the ice thanks for thanks for the 25
bits look lower on the list lower whose
lower I'm looking lower Oh dad man Geum
okay I'll play dead man Geum next game
I'm gonna play the Albin counter gambit
this is opening to try and win in the
quickest fashion Roy Davis oh my
opponent is not listening and he plays
Knight c3 what is 93 let's play e4 I'm
gonna this is gonna be a gambit I'm
sacking this pawn for counter play and
he's not taking it
let's play c6 now we have like some kind
of reverse French except it's not a
French because this Bishop is good so
it's a reverse caro-kann no this is good
for whites let's play g5 g 5 H 5 H 4
chop the bishop
when will I stream next um actually I
have it in my stream schedule I'm
streaming tomorrow dive blunder Queen h5
getting distracted again except skinny
southern keeps me alive I'm streaming
tomorrow for the chest comm arena Kings
tournament at 2 p.m. Central time so
that should be interesting
similar to this position its positions
whack my Kings on u7 but I'm alive
he has no media breakthrough probably go
for a bishop f7 next and then h4 h5 h4
[Music]
Knight b5 he wants to destroy me I think
he wants to put something here here
Bishop f7 doesn't do much this is really
uncomfortable and I'm playing against a
1300 who said earlier is like the
strongest player to walk the earth a
King g7 actually looks reasonable
because now I'm all meeting my bishop my
King can't be checked by the bishop or
the night this is okay check and take
the knight that would be an interesting
queen sac I assume he would play King d1
there and I was considering it let's
play Bishop b4 and then knight c6 it's
completing development pretending my
king is safe which I think it's actually
safe it's still alive you did have
Knight c7 but I would be happy to trade
my rook for his knight now we have a
weird position both of our kings in the
center I would really like to play this
move someday somehow maybe Queen CA
Keaney 7 and then Bishop g4 check that's
a free night
his first blunder of the game so
generous and now I still want to go for
Bishop g4
Gabriel Thomas Newton and Slade in
Brazil good night please play Knight c3
you know you want to or night g3 yes
okay that was nice of him moving on dead
man DM is getting the next challenge the
ultimate leader of the bit war
good luck dead man now I'm gonna stay
focus I'm gonna play like a real opening
unless someone wants to give me like a
challenge everyone that's playing g4
today what is with this so confused like
no one's playing me for anymore
clue says I should play clues let's play
the Budapest
wait what's his rating oh he's a new
person to leech hassles play six not
messing with him oh and he's muting okay
so I can talk freely my plan is to play
a normal opening because he could be a
strong player
seems like he's watching for instructive
value a3 tells me that's okay he's not a
super strong player but he is preventing
some he's preventing my favorite opening
one of my favorite openings let's play
d5 I actually remember preparing this
for someone in like an invitational
event I was playing one of these like
norm round robins and I was preparing
for someone who played eight three early
and I'm trying to remember what I was
prepping there's some how I can make a
three not so useful and it might involve
taking right away but then a three is
useful in these III lines let's play c6
because the goal might be just to take
don't expect too much from me I'm 1200
ish just
okay well that gives me confidence um
let's do this hey ignoble with a hundred
bits
thanks ignoble that was a chill cheer
okay so now we're going into some I
don't even know what we call this the BA
Phoenix system
it's a BA fennec but instead of Knight
f3 he's played a three so that has to
favor me I would think and this could be
a very complex line except in the BA
Phoenix usually they play Bishop h4 g5
and then they take g5 but he doesn't
have a knight to take on g5 with
sometimes that's a problem with playing
those like a three is your other pieces
would rather be in the game a three does
prevent Bishop before it but there's
more important things in life i
blundered a piece but not really this
was actually a very common idea and jess
I remember like when I first started
playing chess I was trying to wrap my
head around this where the knight is
attacked by a pawn that's pinned the
black doesn't lose a piece for free
because h6 happens and if he takes I
take if he'd retreats I play g5 to break
the pin you should do a new episode with
perpetual chess I was actually invited
back on the podcast just to do like a
yearly updates but I've been so busy
with so many things but probably within
the next few months we'll set up an
interview probably after the UM going to
st. Louis again next week so probably
after that whoa okay well dead man is
being very generous with his pawns like
I have not lost a single pawn yet and I
have won two of them
I think maybe he assumed that his knight
could take here and he forgot my queen
is defending which is sad for him but
good for me
hello Manos good to see you back Manas
Winslow award for most badges next to
his name as it possible to get another
badge like what else can you be apart
from a staff member moderator
subscriber and a cheer that's it right
unless I'm missing something
hmm Manas is bringing up a good points I
got caught up I before like when the
stream saw that I said that the stream
was only going to be an hour and then
turned into a lie ah turbo turbo is
something I guess and twitchcon how do
you got a twitch cottage need to go to
the twitchcon Queen f3 is a very clever
move wait no it's not at first I'm
having hallucinations at first I thought
he was attacking this I thought he was
attacking this but nights don't reach
that far also he's blundering another
pawn or is he then he takes back maybe I
should defend this Bishop e7 or Bishop
g7 let's play Bishop g7 or Bishop e7
it's getting late was I trying to say oh
yeah Bishop e7 it restricts his Knights
so essentially his night can't be useful
in moving forward now I might want to
play f5 soon followed by g5
g4 it's really hard to say notation the
later it gets
so when and where is twitchcon because I
would consider going like I have a
flexible enough schedule kind of also is
this another free pawn I'm just gonna
win all his pawns this is so fun
yeah I probably could have played that
five immediately
Colorado has a points but it all works
out in the end like we need five
depending the Knights threatening out
five I'm just gonna be as greedy as
possible and just take everything that's
free and not give him anything if I can
allow it I really want to play a five
but that would allow a trade of pawns I
want to keep all my pawns so let's uh
let's play this move a lot of some
discoveries on this square some
background noise it's crickets outside
so loud okay there should be seven
always a good idea to align your bishop
with so many of your opponent's pieces I
forgot about Knights e5 but that's
giving me another pawn except he could
win f6 let's take it first yeah cuz that
Knight is really annoying and then I'll
play probably play King e7 Keeney seven
looks good enough over defending f6 so I
can win c5 if he doesn't defend it neo
Maddock I'm doing well
I'm getting tired it's getting late and
I have I actually have some work to do
tonight so I have some writing
assignments to do a lot of things going
on I think I mentioned this in a
previous stream but I am looking to hire
someone like a virtual assistants and it
would be useful if they know how to play
chess
so just throwing it out there that's
keep a lookout for some application type
thing this is a free pawn rights
now I'm attacking the rook someday my
bishop will come to life might be fun
for me and Feingold to play a match yes
we know each other we're friendly I've
done work for him I built his Atlantic
chess club website ATL chess club calm
it was one of my like larger freelance
projects but yeah and we've played each
other before I don't think we've played
when we're both streaming I played him
when he's streaming and that was that
and he crushed me
I was unfortunate
shann cold thanks for the comment super
major pain saying hire me and so I'm
saying hiring me you have to say what
value you can bring to me and then maybe
I'll hire you this is a free rook this
is not a free pawn because the Queen
defends let's take the free run
I'm not gonna lose any pawns this game
like we keep trading down this is so
nice oh yeah the job would be to help me
with tasks managing email managing
messages that come across 10 different
platforms what else what I want helping
with YouTube content and like
copywriting 4k descriptions and there's
ok there's a lot of different things
that I would have to probably map out
and then I'll probably make an
application by the end of this year I
will probably hire someone I want to put
a knight on d5 hey some bits from JH SK
good night
yeah it would be remotes I can't imagine
hiring someone and requiring it to be
like in person that would be interesting
though ok
does a person have to be American no it
can be and you from any background but
they should know how to speak English
that would be a major requirement can i
play Knight c3 and trade more stuff no
because he double-checks me in that
means my Knights what to do
King c5 my king is so safe it's being
hugged by all the pieces around it
why did my opponent Castle man game King
safety first
when did he Castle I mean he could play
king d2 but I don't know his King his
King is pretty safe on g1 right let's
play rook to Yeats I really want to play
Knight c3 I probably should have played
Knight c3 other way too late
I'm envisioning some mates where I like
get my Knight to e2 is Kings on each one
and I take on h2 and play rogue h8 mates
let's try and make that happen
I'm also imagining some position where I
keep all my pawns keep both rooks and
then promote to eight rooks and have ten
rooks on the board that would be mean
but also feasible he wants to trade
let's play a five attack the Knights
maybe I'll fix my pawn structure
if he takes my night I could take back
with the pawn and have one pawn island
but he doesn't okay let's play 92 or
let's friend the Bishop on you two also
threatening the rook I am allowing a
trait of rooks
this is looking pretty dead for a dead
man
J we call what is a job for I don't know
what the job is for you you didn't
really miss much I have to I have to
define requirements create a Google Form
for application my opponent resigns
that's sad I was looking forward to
meeting him just to demonstrate just so
I can get the satisfaction if we imagine
like rook a one night a key to this is
what I was hoping for where now it's
it's made into with rook take h2 and
then ricocheted me dead man DM thanks
for the game appreciate the hundred bits
[Music]
okay so there's a lot of people there's
only 16 people challenging me that's not
too much Kluth wanted me to play Kluth
I'm sure all these people want me to
play whatever their username is do I
like the Halloween gambit uh once per
year okay so I'm gonna do is I just lost
it okay so there's a streamer who
recently started streaming and it's
actually we're pretty friendly in person
I'm going to raid her and everyone is
required to join okay
that shouldn't be too hard on the count
of three
one weight I have to type in raid oh the
streamer is is struggling with puzzles
right now okay
goodbye everyone one two